when I was 55 years old and I had been
at the Fed 30 years and decided that I
was a number to officer the New York Fed
first vice president that they weren't
going to make a lawyer the president of
the New York Fed I decided it was time
to move on and I called various people I
knew in the neighborhood and amongst
those was Hank Greenberg and I went and
met with Hank and he was the fastest he
said he'd give me a call in 2 weeks
which he did wages hours conditions of
employment and I had no idea what I was
going to do and I don't think at that
time he had any idea what I was going to
do i work for Hank for a year and i
called myself and it was the role that I
carried out mostly at aig I was a
firefighter for him where there was a
problem dealing with that problem one
off going to be going to the next
problem and it also gave me a chance to
learn the company I mean it was huge
compound complex I got to meet people in
the United States and abroad and get a
feel for the company and then I became
general counsel there but working for
hank was a it was a delight
notwithstanding his reputation
well one he certainly is tough and
resilient those all of those stories are
true there's another side of the man
about how concerned he is about
employees how much loyalty and how
important loyalty was with him you know
stories about when i head auditor in
asia had a heart attack in thailand Hank
stayed up all night on the phone with
doctors from New York Hospital with
doctors in Thailand he would the star
foundation and I don't know if he
started this or carried it out he may
have started it every employee for AIG
and agents of a ipg in the United States
and abroad and these were agents who
were as in Asia they only soul aig
products got a scholarship if their
child went to wane english-language
college in the scholarship amount was
something like ten or eleven thousand
dollars and they had to be financial
need if the child if there was no
financial need because the parent was
making a large enough salaried AIG so
when one looked at the staff
Foundation's annual IRS report name of
individual after individual left to
individual and I really learned the
scope of it one day when I was in the
private dining room waiting for a guest
and this gentleman waiter who was
obviously from mainland China I asked
him what he was going to be doing labor
day and he said he was driving to
Cambridge and I said well why you
driving to Cambridge well we said he was
taking his daughter first-generation
American born to MIT and called it
staller so for people like him that
individual this was rather significant
and and that's something that he that he
really kept up with of course the
amounts of money he gave and the
Foundation's gave to health and medical
you see that at New York Hospital and
but but most of all he truly cared about
employee loyalty was loyalty was
extremely important to him and I think
that came out of perhaps as ami
experience you know when he enlisted
under age in the army
and when you're in the platoon you
develop that amongst people and he he
would sometimes say something like I
wouldn't be in a foxhole that prison
which again goes to loyalty and Trust he
decided that I guess the the head of the
staff foundation was going to be
stepping aside Florence Davis was the
general counsel was going to become the
head of the staff foundation I think
Florence still is and he asked me to be
general counsel and that was a unique
experience in that I had reorganized the
legal department at the New York Fed
when i was there is general counsel at
aig i had to reorganize the the legal
department and put it into some
semblance and it took awhile to get a
feel for people and that really for the
first i would say nine months to a year
was my major task was organizing this
gigantic legal department and even when
i left eight years later I'd say it was
still a work in progress
you know schiller at Yale wrote a book
that's his name and told us that we had
this huge real estate bubble I I didn't
read the book but I I knew what he was
saying an awful lot of people knew about
it I the way I look at it there's no
single cause this event as horrendous as
it is took an awful lot of people
working hard to get us there it's bank
supervisors not doing their job its
directors and management of financial
organizations not doing their job it's
Congress not doing its job with Ginny
Mae and Fannie Mae I can go on and on
with a large list it's the securitizers
who were securitizing you know it had no
skin in the game in terms of the loans
they working yet it was the investment
banks who would specify the nature of
the securitized products and what those
loans must call for it was the rather
slimy the brokers for real estate
lending in mortgage bankers it was snl's
federal SNL's who would have these
transactions go through them for usury
purposes who really didn't care what the
transactions were it just it just goes
on and on the Fed interest rates too low
so it it's really i think inappropriate
to say it's any one person when I think
it's a systemic event and that's what we
have is a systemic event you know it's
really society is to blame not any
single group of people and we shouldn't
punish any single group of people but
our firm gave a presentation last
februari and I think we listed two full
pages of what i call the villains
well at AIG AIG FP financial products
the swap sub to me financial products
was unique amongst the AIG subsidiaries
it was almost as if it was not a part of
AIG it was extremely independent and set
up to be that way and it also was I
think unique in that four of the holding
company directors were on the board of
AIG FP is mr. Greenberg on how we Smith
the CFO bruni aidan off retired from
Sullivan & Cromwell and Matty Feldstein
I don't know when hank was pushed out
because I didn't have my relationship
with these people like they put their
arms out and kept kept me away as others
and they were successful in doing it
because Hank supported them being
separate I don't know what kind of
oversight was being carried on when we
were redoing the annual report in 2005
and afterwards I'm happy to say the
trades were put on after I left but I
wouldn't have known about it anyway the
way it was run and I also don't have a
full understanding of what happened with
risk management that AIG was perhaps one
of the few firms that had early on had
market risk at both the level of the
profit center and in the holding company
what did happen is that the senior
market rates market risk officer retired
there was a reorganization and he was
going to report to somebody and I think
he decided that he rather not report to
someone he had been reporting directly
to Hank and had a good rapport with Hank
and he had a feel for financial products
and he was tough enough to deal with
them with him gone I suspect we lost
some edge and with Hank gone we lost an
edge and so the thought about the
massive bailout because of the needs of
collateral you know I don't know why all
those trades were put on but what we're
seeing now is for many of them you know
that the risk was market value risk it
was the same thing as
long-term capital management you know at
aig berkshire hathaway and goldman sachs
were going to buy long-term capital
management's book it was the book would
be in the money at maturity it was baked
in the cake profit it just didn't have
the capital to get there and we got we
didn't get a chance to do the
transaction because of a meeting at the
new york fed in the same way i am
guessing now I don't know that financial
products book may well be in the money
yes they're probably something bad
credit default swaps but some of that
collateral was starting to come back so
it was the need for massive amounts that
the way FP ran is every transaction was
guaranteed by the holding company by a
IJ which was then Triple A which was
then double a and there were triggers in
the swaps so when AI GF we IG was
downgraded and affected FP put all of
those events together and the massive
needs for for collateral that the banks
were unwilling to put up maybe it was
just too much for them or they they
couldn't see it all but that was a shock
to the system in terms of size but not
as big a shock to the system is lehman I
mean I don't I don't I think AIG was
sort of gravy I think the real massive
amount was the the Lehman shock to the
system of the Lehman failure after the
bear stearns bailout
I think they were both had a mistaken
view and I think though the thought
really if I can recall being correctly
really is that the product could
withstand it that the investors who
invested in these products were all
mature adults able to invest by side
investors many of the triple-a tranches
were acquired by banking organizations
who thought they were safe even though
they end and they bought credit default
swap insurance on it I think there was
just too much of an assumption that the
product would take care of himself that
if there were defaults the people the
risk was spread the whole the whole
thought of credit default swap and
securitization was the spreading of risk
and I think what we've learned is yes
you can spread it but the other part of
it was you couldn't get rid of it
because of the lack of liquidity in the
market and I really see the major issue
in the major signal for me was early on
when there was no 30 60 90 day money in
the market and people with positions
couldn't finance themselves and I think
the Fed was a little slow to pick that
up but I I think too much assuredness in
the product will be interesting to see
when when the product does come back in
a major way will it just come back again
in the same way that there won't be any
features on it that will yield control
in the banking organization so that they
can get these off balance sheet not have
some of them come back like there are
coming back but i but i think there was
just too much of an assumption that this
product worked but we and it probably
you know i guess we'd have to look back
to the last recession and say you know
there really weren't a lot of issues in
housing of a great degree securitize
housing in the last recession so we we
lacked experience and the major concern
on securitizations were in a market of
falling interest rates people doing
refinancing and we didn't see that in
this market perhaps we're seeing a
little
now when when when people can do it but
I think the answer is to be a little
more skeptical of the product I'm
disappointed in the buy side we've had a
lot of criticism of the south side which
is deserve but a lot of the people
buying these products were institutional
investors
the bailout good AIG counterparties well
I guess they were bailed out I don't
know what that means ISM does it mean if
AIG had failed I don't fully understand
the question is is it assumed that AIG
failed and the failure of AIG would
cause knock-on failures of other firms
would have to be bailed out if AIG were
in a bankruptcy proceeding it would have
been messy I really saw the aji problem
in another light I think we saw if I
remember press promotes correctly the
beginning of some runs in Asia life
insurance in Asia is a savings product I
think asians will gamble on anything
except their lives and there were some
runs and that would have had a
horrendous effect and countries where AG
was a major insurer taiwan thailand
philippines hong kong huge problems
there plus the knock-on effects here of
the major banking organizations who were
the counterparties who needed the
collateral so I I think it was a variety
of issues and if AIG had gone into
bankruptcy I think the subsidiaries
would have had a hard time continuing in
businesses at least as I see it chatters
now the AIG property and casualty
subsidiary is you know percolating along
doing doing fairly well you know it's
it's taking a beating with competitors
the the life insurance company in the
States is doing fairly fairly well the
companies outside the united states are
doing fairly well so it's very
interesting AIG had a flat organization
chart with profit centers and with the
exception of financial products and then
those who needed financing I mean the
ILFC the aircraft leasing company has
you know huge amounts of money to roll
over good company well-run and the
issues certainly not creditworthiness
but financing and then a aiji's subprime
lending sub there's learned there are
different kinds of
prime lending there's the good subprime
loans and the bad subprime loans and and
that subsidiary was doing fairly well
the last time I talked to people so what
I CAG is doing is just exacerbating a
far worse problem the the Lehman shock
to the system the AIG shocked enforces
it and AIG has really become much more
of a political issue with because of the
amount of the bailout
well if if we had something like the
proposed legislation which would cover
AIG because it has a federal savings
bank then AIG itself could have become
part of a bridge bank in other words the
holding company in effect would be there
in all its assets transfer it it would
have adversely affected the shareholders
and whatever creditors would not
transfer it over and can continued in
business this this is the resolution
that's being considered by Congress
which i think is helpful for
institutions who live on liquidity and
liquidity is very important to them so
that if that resolution authority had it
been in place it would have been a lot
easier to do it instead of this thing
with the Fed lend some money in the
Treasury lend some money and there's a
lot of opaqueness to that one really has
to drill down to to understand it all
but but a bankruptcy for me IG would
have affected all of the the
subsidiaries I think and it would have
been in much worse shape than today
I you know I really don't see it I look
at my own career 30 years at the Fed
where I did a lot of supervision I will
have friends in commercial investment
banks that didn't affect me when it came
to doing remedial work I think the
answer is we got things done faster
because we know each other we dealt with
each other over the years I really don't
see regulatory capture and then this
goes to a whole other point that like to
get into if anyone hasn't asked the
question that is the structure of the
Federal Reserve Bank's each federal
reserve bank has nine directors three of
them were appointed by the Board of
Governors including the chairman and
deputy chairman of the Reserve Bank and
six are elected by shareholders and
they'll be I call it one's a big bank
director one's a medium Bank director
wants a small Bank director and the
others commerce industry agriculture
labor and they do not get into bank
supervision at the Fed where they help
the Fed is in terms of what they see in
the economy what people are telling them
these are usually people leaders in
their area be it a union or banking
business organization global institution
and provide a lot of insight into what's
going on in the economy and every two
weeks they meet and they vote on a
interest rate and then that goes down to
the board of governors in Washington
along with a message which sums up the
directors feelings of up down to stay to
say and then is not effective until
approved by the Board of Governors that
has system has worked so well over the
years about giving intelligence to the
Reserve Bank's to the Board of Governors
again these people do not get involved
in bank supervision some people want to
change that and in effect want to make
the Reserve Bank's much closer to the
federal government than they are today
and I I think that's not going to happen
I've asked myself why over the years at
the federal reserve bank of new york
where people in the community so willing
to tell us
things wrong and going on that we wrong
and I remember once an SEC chairman
saying why is it they call you and they
don't call me and the and the answer is
I don't think capture I think it's trust
relationships over the years being in
being in the market and that's an issue
that's being pushed on and I just don't
think it's a I don't think it's right
I don't think that size alone is an
issue I mean if every institution does
the right thing they're reporting fully
the amounts they spent on lobbying I
know when I was at aig we were
scrupulous about it we always wondered
about whether the other firms were
scrupulous as we were in terms of
reporting what we did I would go not
monthly but periodically go and visit
not to lobby but to let people on the
hill know where we were going directions
issues things like that I don't know
that large institutions what about like
I didn't hear large labor unions in that
statement I didn't hear about other
organizations in that statement and
smaller institutions also have
organizations financial and otherwise
there are the trade associations I don't
think it's any more product i've always
thought in banking no bank could get a
law they might be able to slow one down
a new law but but very very difficult
for a bank to say here's what we want
please enact and i just don't see that
kind of capture of the hill
I think it would have been different in
in degree of severity we still would be
going through this crisis I just think
the shock of the system was too strong
and we didn't show the resolve that we
needed to and then when it came to
issues like the legislation how poorly
the bill was handled the top bill was
handled both in the administration and
Congress so the knock-on of the Lehman
was as equally as bad as the decision
not to save Lehman we'd still have all
the problems with credit worthiness and
those securitizations today but I but I
i think the severity would have been
tempered somewhat
I don't office 2007 or earlier when
there was gridlock in the marketplace I
remember there was an early intervention
by the European Central Bank putting
liquidity into the market it was massive
and the Fed followed and put in less
liquidity and I said to myself gosh look
at those guys in Frankfurt you know
they're trying to look like heroes
taking this major action and the Fed was
just following to show that that they
were there and I looked back at that one
and said to myself I was absolutely
wrong in terms of my judgment about it
that the ECB had it right and more
liquidity should have been provided to
the market earlier on again not a
cure-all but perhaps could have tempered
the impact on the market someone
you know I think that the question I
guess for the counterparties at AIG and
this is a major issue and not just swaps
but in the wholesale market and that is
to what extent do participants in their
market know the current financial
position of their counterparties and I
think the answer is people don't ask
they just deal with each other and this
has been a question for 20 years why
should i do the trade with you what's
your financial condition today and then
one answer as well if it's an
institution that trades a lot it can be
completely different tomorrow in terms
of the financial condition the credit
default swap as an instrument has been
unfairly attacked now i have my
prejudice i was on the board of is de
the swaps trade association for a number
of years but i think the product worked
well it continues to be a product that
gives us price on on securities and it's
a good indication of price on securities
outside of AIG it's worked well in
lehman there used to be issues on
documentation and I credit Tim Geithner
in terms of puffing up as should have
been done long ago on the need for for
firms to tighten up and get their
litigation that they'll the
documentation complete and someone was
telling me of the number of trades that
Lehman has a huge number of trades only
one resulted in litigation regarding the
validity of the trade because of
documentation so I think the swap worked
well that's not to say that there's not
a need for stand that I swaps to be deal
help dealt with on on trading platforms
and settlement mechanisms for regulators
you know for example the basil basil to
perhaps in dealing with the trading book
as opposed to the credit book perhaps
didn't have a high enough capital charge
it's not to say everything was perfect
but I think the credit default swap was
deemed to be the evil instrument because
of AIG at AIG it was an issue of risk
management
and I put these two and say the two
keywords for the next several years in
terms of Banking Supervision equality of
risk management and quality of liquidity
management
I don't know that's I read the papers
and say yes Goldman Sachs was a major
counterparty and there were many stories
in the market about debates between
Goldman Sachs and AIG on valuations and
things like that that we're a bit
strange so when when someone writes the
book maybe they'll be able to give us
more insight as to really what was going
on there
well I mean if they were getting
collateral from AIG and it was good
quality collateral you know this you
know what were they doing with it
they're probably read pledging it
hopefully they were repledge it with
collateral and receiving back something
that was liquid so that they would have
the opportunity if they needed to pay it
back as rates change market rates change
so to me we're talking about collateral
it it it is an issue of where is my
collateral with a counter body that will
be focused on by examiners they random
charged on my swap will depend in part
if I have to put up collateral whether I
let my counter potty Rhea pathak ate the
collateral to another party will people
become nervous i had Winston swear there
was a client who was posting collateral
with the bank and the central bank of
that country guaranteed all deposits so
the client said to the to the
counterparty branch of a foreign bank
here in New York I want to place that
collateral with the bank in the foreign
country where it's a hundred percent
guaranteed so in a nervous world will
see things like things like that happen
and nothing keeps me up at night I sleep
well every night if you ask me what I
think about when I'm awake it is I hope
we don't double dip as an economy I
think that's one concern that we that we
prick along we don't have a fast up and
then a damn we don't have a V we don't
drop down again over the longer term I
hope that the Fed when it when it has to
and exceeds now certainly not the time
but when it comes time to really
increase rates that the Fed doesn't that
the that the will is there and i look at
the Fed and say there are seven
governors there are two openings now and
that probably will be more i would
suspect that one or two of the present
governors could possibly leave and that
would give President Obama five out of
seven I would be his people and that has
the potential to cause a problem if
jaron banake wants to go one way the Fed
is not a monolithic Beast the Chairman's
a powerful person always has been but
you know the decisions recover the
Federal Open Market Committee require a
vote of 12 so when I talk when interest
rates and I read economists say look at
this look at this look at this I say
look to see when you see the first
descent at a federal open market
committee meeting on interest rates then
we'll know we're on the way someone will
be ahead of the curve may be too early
but it takes one brave probably Reserve
Bank president to do it but we should
have the spirit to go back to the
non-inflationary course that we had
before we all know it's an issue it's no
secret and I have no reason to believe
the Fed won't do it but I can feel
uneasy